now it's time for puppy pig skin picks
from subaru of las vegas and kelsey's
with us here from the anna foundation
how's it going
good how are you i am mostly sunny it is
a beautiful day
and who is this young lady this is bella
and she has the most beautiful color
coloring she's about eight years young
she is such a sweetheart she is a staff
favorite over at the shelter we don't
know why she hasn't been adopted yet
she likes to go on walks and i can tell
you she loves car rides because she
loved the car right over here
do we know what kind of a breed she is
we don't we usually don't uh
label with breeds at the shelter just
because we want people to get to know a
dog for
who they are she's a bigger girl not
someone you would take to run marathons
or anything like that just kind
of wants to chill and relax at home with
our humans
and you were telling me that there's a
special going on right now with the
animal foundation
correct so fees would be waived for
bella here
uh we're doing home for the holidays
which is our special promotion
and adoption fees are waived for large
dogs and adult cats right now
awesome well bella are you ready to pick
a winner between the
saints and the chiefs head on over there
and tell us who you think is going to
win that football game
oh she's picking the chiefs oh well and
the saints
but we'll go with the chiefs bella good
luck and hopefully someone will take
bella home
thank you thank you if you want to adopt
bella remember you have to make an
appointment at the animal foundation
these days there's the number on your
screen
sherry